so he's a high-ranking commander in the
Russian army he's been commanded 58th
Army which is the uh the the one of the
units that broke through a mariopal last
year and is the current focus of much of
the Ukrainian counter-offensive uh he's
a very high ranking figure he's a major
general which is a very high rank in the
Russian army extremely well respected uh
but the blow up in the last 48 hours has
been extremely substantial
um he has been relieved of his command
has been replaced his success has
already been put in position and amongst
the complaints uh that the major general
pop-off has made is first about the lack
of
um defense systems as you just mentioned
but also about the fatigue of many of
his troops who are not being rotated out
to be able to rest unlike as he says as
ukrainians who are fighting against so
it's it's a sign I think of of great
morale problems within the Russian front
lines and also some of the senior
figures daring to speak out being
removed from position quickly and Dr
Franklin let's just remind our viewers
because you and I know this because
we're kind of obsessed with what goes on
with this one and the back and forth but
this the details of the way that this uh
individual resigned came out through
sort of Russian social media so that in
and of itself is kind of fascinating
that he would sort of release his
criticism of of high command online like
that
well it's an interesting it's a it's a
great question I mean Russia has a
state-controlled media so reporting of
the war in Ukraine
um is all handled by the state in many
provincial parts of Russia there's
there's almost well there's very little
coverage of the war at all uh and so the
narrative gets control but since the war
started uh in particular the telegram
News Channel a secure encrypted uh
operation has allowed bloggers uh
commentators and uh individuals not
least uh jurgeni prigojin to be able to
send messages to their followers and
that means that we're getting a sort of
second version of what's been happening
in Russia as it happens it wasn't pop-up
who released the recording but his
predecessor as commander of the 58th
Army who is um in the Senate as a sorry
he's in the state Duma as a deputy or as
an MP effectively
um I think to try to drum up support for
Popov but also to point to The Wider
issues being faced by the Russian troops
at the moment and that low morale
against a resurgence ukrian um
counter-offensive now obviously you are
paying close attention to these kind of
pronouncements by by these people but
every time I as you mentioned you know
State media controls the narrative so
closely in Russia and then we hear about
this low morale we hear about these
criticisms of a gracimov and and umigu
um do we believe them
yes I think it's a real challenge for a
war situation that is draining Russia's
economy uh the the the the ability to
keep the economy on the you know keeping
on moving is not easy a lot of small
businesses being very heavily taxed
there's been a big brain drain uh the
Russian war effort is extremely
expensive both politically and
financially for Moscow and so the the
any form of criticism is obviously falls
on very sensitive ground because uh
Putin doesn't like criticism anyway but
also in a situation where everybody has
to line up behind behind the boss uh any
form of descent is to be heavily
criticized so you know I think this
needs to be seen in the context of
what's happened in the last two or three
weeks since uh who was very vocal in his
criticisms in particular of the defense
against him off ahead of the Russian
army to flag some of the same issues
that pop-up has been flagging now
Popper's popularity I mean his message
was aimed at his own men
um but his popularity within the Russian
Armed Forces had spilled over this
evening into lots of commentary through
other commentators on
um on telegram who are very sympathetic
to what Popov has been saying and have
reacted quite badly to his removal from
office and positions some have actually
been saying maybe he's going to be given
a different position I suspect that's
not how things really will work in the
next coming weeks and months but I think
there is a real a bigger issue around
here about
um people in Russia realizing what the
war is actually costing and whether
that's going to dislodge some kind of
attempt to bring some sort of pressure
on Putin to bring the war to an end
through one way or another and last
thought on the Russian military and it
might be really quick cancer I do want
to move on to Nato with you Dr Frank
panwala have you but General Sullivan
General Armageddon hasn't been seen
since pregosian's uh Mutiny where is he
and what do we think has happened to
this man
uh you know your guess is as good as
mine and I suspect as good as many of
the viewers uh you know Russia is a
complicated place and the complicated
things can happen in complicated ways uh
that sometimes defy the odds I mean we
all thought big ocean was going to be
living out the rest of his days in a
Dutch in in minutes or in Belarus that
doesn't seem to be right so I think
we're trying to predict what might be
happening to sort of ekin uh is a little
bit premature I think that the the
bigger picture though including pregojin
sort of he can again Asimov and
shoiguous these are really important
figures at the top of the Russian high
command and the fact that there are
wobbles suggest that that Unity that
Putin has managed to keep together
behind him for the last 16 months it may
not be quite fracturing but I think
there are obviously questions being
asked about competence and about
logistics and that from their scale all
sorts of other questions around if you
can't get those two simple things right
then um you know what are you fighting
for and and that must be bubbling behind
the scenes to work out what it is that
Putin and or Russia will want and it is
there is there potentially end in sight
for this war and Dr Frank pan then just
a final thought then on Reflections
following the NATO Summit I mean Ukraine
probably got as close to to what it
wanted as it was going to get at a time
when it you know is at war with with
Russia talk to us if you can and wrap up
all into your answer because I've got
loads of time the uh introduction of
Sweden what benefits that brings and how
you see the alliance backing uh Ukraine
going forward
the simple answer is that um
Europe has become much more united than
perhaps it had been before before the
war had started both in terms of
military and nato in its expansion to
include Scandinavian countries Finland
and Sweden but also in the corporation
towards defending Ukraine I think from
other parts of the world that's seen in
a very different way in China for
example uh the expansion of NATO to
include Scandinavian countries and
potentially uh Ukraine is seen as a way
of the West setting the rules for its
Club about who can join and when and
that that other countries have a
different way of forming alliances and
so there is a kind of a block that has
formed that looks different depending on
where you're standing on on the planet
at the moment and I think NATO's lean
into native to Ukraine has in some ways
been a fudge in the last few days
because we've neither said Ukraine will
join nor that they won't and probably
the lack of clarity is helpful for those
who are less keen on on seeing that
Unity that's been a feature of the last
16 months